thank you
your brothers and sisters in the slam
nap from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawa Center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah
azzawajal will give you even
how are you guys doing I'm here with a
notorious man a man that you may have
known through my channel an individual
who has single-handedly been able to
take the Dao to the next level not just
in Norway but in all of Scandinavia
unfortunately he can be joined with me
today but we do have fun
hey there brother
uh well in Norway I should say I mean
um but there's been a phenomena which
has really emerged I don't know why or
who started this or what started this
but this phenomenon of burning the holy
books of the Muslims and is spreading
like wildfire no no pun intended like
wildfire throughout Scandinavia and
you've been dealing uh with this uh
what's going on as a context here to be
honest this thing started back in 2019
where this guy large proportion he was
doing a Quran burning demonstration and
from that time he's just it's just been
escalating and now it's just come to the
stage that these guys are even any
fighting people in the street and they
are spraying security guards with paint
in their faces actually I could show you
a video I could show the viewers a video
as well well let's take a look at the
video that you're talking about I'm sure
there's more than one of them yes
because I've heard many things about
this individual well let's look at the
first video and then reacting kind
of
[Music]
in the heart
she cleared us something
[Music]
um
so as we saw here the security guard
from what I've just seen here he's just
extinguishing the fire of the of the
Quran outside of his vicinity of work
and then he was assaulted because of it
now I mean this shows you the vile and
intolerant nature of these individuals
who are claiming to represent liberalism
and freedom I mean what exactly did you
make of this that to be honest this
accident or this incident it was all
over the Norwegian news so alhamdulillah
even though the government they allowed
the burning of the Quran they did not
accept that then he is attacking a god
like that that's good line somewhere
exactly so this was taken to the police
and this guy was actually taken to trial
to court and he was judged for that so
he will be in jail for that yeah
alhamdulillah well I mean this shows you
that I mean the right wing nature or you
could say the violent nature of the
right wing movement here I mean they're
claiming isn't it so ironic pathetic I
only actually at that that these
individuals who are claiming that
they're defending themselves in Islam
are assaulting people of work people
that have got jobs unlike most of them
what do you make of that because this is
really seeming to be now these guys are
getting violent to be honest the only
thing or the only solution I see to this
problem is that we need to combat this
kind of islamophobia and we need to do
something about the problem we've seen
terrorist attacks in Norway not once but
two times uh any private who killed 77
people in Cold Blood just because they
were the government or the political
party the labor party was supportive of
Muslims according to him so he believes
that they like any murtaz in his in his
crazy way of thinking and he thought it
was legitimate to kill them and he did
that and in 2019 we had Philip man's
house who actually went to the Masjid
with guns ready to kill the Muslims for
the Pakistani uncle just dealt with but
we we can't just sit down to sit back
and wait for these terrorists to come to
our mosques and do these kinds of crazy
acts like we need to fight the
islamophobia and one of the major major
ways we can do that is by enlightening
the society giving thou or telling them
about Islam what what the what the
religion of Islam really teaches and
we're doing that through the Masjid and
dawah Center that we're establishing in
this country absolutely and from my
understanding of the initiative and you
can correct me if I'm wrong but you know
in the the knowledge part of the
knowledge production of Islam is
actually that you're going to facilitate
or you're going to have an entire Islam
anti-slamophobia branch is that correct
you're going to be intellectually
dealing with disseminating information
educating the people that would have the
net effect of dealing with islamophobia
yeah inshallah we will do that together
yes you will be preparing the course and
delivering this course in in Norway and
any and teaching the duat in Scandia the
Navy how to deal with these kinds of
wild behavior from these islamophobes
and how we as a Muslim Community should
react to this absolutely guys and this
is uh exactly what we need your help
with because quite frankly you know I
have been a partner with a team member
of working with islamnet for some time
now some years since it's a peace
conference and these are reliable people
I mean I've you know come many times
knowing seen what they've done but
northern new northern Europe in
particular and the Scandinavian region
needs us we've seen what happened in
Sweden just recently with this
individual burning the Quran which got
International attention so this I would
say now is starting to pick up traction
we are starting the intellectual fight
back and I think we're winning but we'll
win even more with your help which is
why we need your help now because quite
frankly we won't be able to do this
alone and we do require the monetary
charitable support of the public which
has already gone so far in being able to
counter the anti-islamic and
islamophobic narratives what will you do
with the money as you have already done
with it so inshallah we we're in the
middle of a big Expansion Project of the
premise we need proper facilities
educational facilities in this premise
so we can do these kinds of courses and
do these kinds of Islamic work so we
won't do any
refurbish this whole building into a
proper Islamic dawa Institute so we can
just propagate The Message of Islam and
for that we need your support guys
brothers and sisters it's the month of
Ramadan one of the best times of the
year to give for the sake of Allah and
every single dollar that you give for
the sake of Allah for this specific
cause
it will be amazing it would just it
would create amazing results for us for
the work for the dawa and for your and
also for your children and your
grandchildren and your
great-grandchildren because we are
leaving a World Behind where it has to
be hospitable enough for them to be able
to live to become active members of
society not get bullied in schools not
get uh discriminated in workplaces be
able to live functional lives in the
west if we don't deal with this problem
now we won't even be able to survive in
the west so this is of the greatest
importance and the highest imperative
click the link below
told us
that when the son of Adam dies
finished except for three things
a continuous charity and a beneficial
knowledge and also a righteous offspring
that makes Dua for him your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center and
fulfilling a great portion of this
Hadith on your behalf establishing a
message to convey The Message of Islam
is one of the best Deeds a Muslim can do
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale so give
generously and Allah azzawajal will give
you
[Music]